the law before us today is urgent
elektriciteitsbedrijven to pay taxes
per tonne c o
2 that is released during their valuable work
namely
generating cheap and reliable electricity
for all Dutch people
the union already obliges companies for rights
to buy for the emission of c
o 2
but with this law the
the thumbstrokes tightened even further
yes the purpose of this law is that the emissions of c
o 2 becomes so expensive
that all reliable
Cola and gas plants
that generate most of our electricity
are no longer profitable
and will have to be replaced by unreliable ones
bibelstrom such as winter beaners and solar panels
of which it is not sure at what time
would not supply 1 power
for if The Wind does not blow and if the sun does not shine
the Netherlands has no electricity